التراجع عن التعديلات القضائيه
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي يدخل على خط
الازمه ويحث قاده اسرائيل على ايجاد حل
وسط في اقرب وقت
روسيا تقلص عدد جنودها في بيلاروسيا الى
اربعه الاف وجنود الاوكرانيون ينهون
تدريباتهم على الدبابات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في نشاط مفصل من
العربيه ونبدا من اسرائيل التي تعيش على
صفيح ساخن منذ اسابيع لكن حرارته زادت
خلال 48 ساعه الماضيه بعد اقاله نتنياهو
لوزير دفاعه كره الناري او الثلج تتدحرج
نحو مكتب نتنياهو الشارع غاضب ونواب حزب
غير راضيين والجامعات منتفضه اليوم جاء
الدور على رئيس البلاد اسحاق هرتسوك الذي
دخل على الخط وفي التفاصيل مشاهدينا حث
الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق حكومه على وقف
الاصلاح القضائي المتنازع عليه بشده بعد
يوم من اقاله رئيس الوزراء لوزير دفاعه
المعارض لخطه تغيير القضاء وضع هيرسوغا
الحكومه الاسرائيلي عبر حسابه على تويتر
الى وقف العمليه التشريعي على الفور من
اجل وحده شعب اسرائيل وتحملا للمسؤوليه
على حد تعبيره
ورغم دعوات وقف التعديلات القضائيه اقرت
لجنه الدستور بالكنيست مشروع القانون
بالقراءتين الثانيه والثالثه ورفعته
للجلسه العامه ياتي هذا وسط بيان
للمحتاجين دعا الى محاصره الكنيست بعد ظهر
اليوم وتنفيذ اضرابات واسعه في كل
القطاعات الحيويه للضغط من اجل التراجع عن
التعديلات القضائيه واعاده وزير الداخليه
بعدما قاله رئيس الوزراء
واشار مراسل العربيه الى توقعات باعلان
نتنياهو في خطابه اليوم تعليق التعديلات
القضائيه واجراء حوار شامل بشانها بعد
ضغوط من وزراء حزب اليكود ومحامي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المشاهدين الى هذا الخبر العاجل اذا
بنقفير وزير الامن الداخليه الاسرائيليه
من حل الحكومه اذا اعلن تعليق التعديلات
القضائيه في اجواء هذه الازمه مشاهدينا
حذر اثنان من الاحزاب التي تمثل اقصى
اليمين في الحكومه الاسرائيليه من التراجع
نقاط التعديلات القضائيه وقال حزب
الصهيوني الديني الذي يتزعمه وزير الماليه
ان التراجع عن التعديلات القضائيه يعني
الاستسلام لفاشيه الاقليات بحسب تعبيره
مؤكدا رفضه القاطع لوقف تمرين القانون
بالكنيست كما قال وزير الامن الداخلي
اتمار بن جفير ان التعديلات القضائيه يجب
ان يتم تمريرها تحت اي ظرف
مشاهدينا من القدس العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا
بكوره كبيره في الداخل الاسرائيلي وعلى
اكثر من صعيد ما الذي يتوقع ان نسمعه من
خطاب نتنياهو اليوم
حاليا نتنياهو يزال مجتمعا مع رؤساء
الائتلاف وباعتقاد قد يطول هذا الاجتماع
بمعنى قد يؤجل قليلا الكلمه او الخطاب
للاسرائيليين وذلك بسبب الصعوبات التي
يواجهها بالضبط فيما اسلبته قبل قليل في
المقدمه بنج فير عمليا
الحزبان
المتطرفان في الحكومه يحاولان منع نتنياهو
من اعلان تجميد او تعليق او وقف التشريعات
عمليا ويضغطان عليه ويهددان حتى
باسقاط الائتلاف بطبيعه الحال المتوقع ان
يقوله نتنياهو بانه سيعلق
التشريعات الخاصه بخطه اصلاح القضاء او
انقلاب على نظام القضاء في اسرائيل الى ما
بعد الاعياد اليهوديه اي على الاقل شهر من
الان وانه سيدخل في مفا مع كافه الاطراف
بهدف التوافق على صيغه توفيقيه لكن قد لا
يكون ذلك كافيا بالضروره بالنسبه لمنظمين
الاحتجاجات لانهم اعلنوا مسبقا بانهم لن
يكتفوا بتعليق التشريعات وانما يطالبون
بالغائها وشطبيها من اجنده اسرائيل
وبهذا المعنى يعني قد يكون هذا ما يزال
خطر قائم خاصه وان اليمين ونتنياهو عمليا
عن مدى صباح هذا اليوم الى استكمال نهائي
لتحضير القوانين للتصويت في الكنيست في
لجنه القانون والدستور وبمعنى اخر هذا
يبقى سيفا مسلا على الشارع الاسرائيلي
فيما بعد ولهذا
منظمي نرى منظمين الاحتجاجات قد يرفضون
الامر الاخر سكرتير النقابات المهنيه
والعماليه في اسرائيل
محاطا برؤساء البلديات في اسرائيل على
فكره معظم هؤلاء من حزب الليكود اعلن
اضرابا شاملا في اسرائيل
ودعا نتنياهو الى ضروره وقف التشريعات او
ما وصفه بالانقلاب على القضاء في اسرائيل
طيب هل هناك زياد خشيه من خروج الامور عن
السيطره امنيا ما هي ابرز مخاوف الاجهزه
الامنيه ونحن نتحدث ايضا عن اجتماعا لهيئه
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي لبحث داعيات اقاله
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ايضا
بالامس خرجت الامور عن السيطره اغلق شارع
ايالون وهو العصب الرئيسي لوسط اسرائيل في
تل ابيب 11 ساعه هذا لم يسبق في تاريخ
اسرائيل ان تم قطع الطريق واشعال الاطارات
هذه المشاهد لا تعادها اسرائيل وبالتالي
الشعور العام كان لدى كل الاطراف بان
الامور خرجت عن السيطره الى درجه ان
قياديين في حزب الليكود دعوني تنياهو الى
اقاله وزير العدل الاسرائيلي لفين لانه
اوصل اسرائيل او كاد الى حرب الى شفا حرب
اهليه هذا ما هذه الخشيه الاساسيه التي
بدات تتبلور خاصه الليله الماضيه لان هذه
المظاهرات للتذكير كانت تلقائيه خرج نحو
نصف مليون في في مجمل اسرائيل بشكل تلقائي
بدون دعوه للتظاهر وهذا عمليا دق ناقوس
الخطر لدى كل المؤسسات في اسرائيل الخشن
الاساسيه لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي والاجهزه
الامنيه هي خشيه مضاعفه اولا داخليا بسبب
امكان تفكك الجيش الاسرائيلي بسبب العصيان
العسكري وخارجيا بان يقرا ما يحدث في
اسرائيل ضعفا وان يغري ذلك جهات خارجيه
لان تجرب ماهيه ما يحدث في اسرائيل عسكريا
وان كانت تقدير بان ذلك بعيدا يحدث لان
اسرائيل عمليا تقوم بالعمل ذاتيا من حيث
شبه الانهيار الداخلي طيب اسمح لي زياد
بتذكير بالاخبار العجله ورد على الشاشه
قبل قليل رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
والامن بالكنيسه يتحدث عن ان الوقت ليس
مناسبا لاقاله وزير الدفاع زياد التظاهرات
ايضا يبدو انها انتقلت الى مرحله شارع
مقابل شارع وذلك بالحديث عن تظاهرات ايضا
خرجت مؤيده لنتنياه الحاكم يوم امس وامس
الاول ايضا
هل كان حضورا فاعلا وكبيرا واحدث حاله من
التوازن بين الطرفين يمكن ان نقول
ابدا هذا غير صحيح عمليا في التوصيف لا
يوجد شارع في مقابل شارع حقيقه الامر هناك
الشارع الاسرائيلي بنسبه حوالي 70% يعارض
الخطه وبالتالي معظم المظاهرات الكبرى
الحاشده كانت لصالح
المحتجين والمعارضين للخطه وليس لانصار
اليمين انصار اليمين لم يحشدوا مظاهرات
كبيره في اسرائيل
صحيح صحيح وبالتالي كان صوتهم عال ولكن
عددهم قليل نسبيا خاصه في المدن التي
تعتبر معاقل لليمين التي ذهب المحتجون
اليها وراينا ذلك في اور عكيبه مثلا في
شمال اسرائيل هذا معقل للكود كان هناك
مشدات وكان هناك عمليا مظاهره نوعا ما
كبيرا لانصار نتنياه ولكن في المجمل لا
يوجد عمليا مواجهه ما بين الاغلبيه
البرلمانيه لنتنياهو في الكنيست وما بين
الشارع الاسرائيلي
طيب زياد التفضل بالبقاء معي ساعود اليك
في سياق هذه النشره
ومشاهدينا حذر وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
المقالينت من ان الانقسام الراهنه في
المجتمع بسبب التعديلات القضائيه يمثل
خطرا على الامن ويهدد مستقبل اسرائيل
وقالت خلال جلسه للجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
والامن في كنيسه
بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده مع استمرار
الاحتجاجات
افادت وسائل اعلام الاسرائيليه بان القنصر
العام الاسرائيلي في نيويورك اساسزمير قدم
استقالته بعد اقاله وزير الدفاع وقال
القنصل في تغريده على تويتر ان الوضع في
اسرائيل وصل الى لحظه حرجه وانه يشعر
بالمسؤوليه عميقه والتزام اخلاقي للنضال
من اجل القيام الديمقراطيه واضاف اساف
سمير قائلا ان القرار الخطير باقاله وزير
الدفاع اقنعه بانه لم يعد يستطيع تمثيل
هذه الحكومه
وفي اول ردود على ما يجري في اسرائيل اعرب
البيت الابيض عن قلقه ازاء تطورات بعد
اقاله وزير الدفاع وافغانا في مصيبه بسبب
رفضه للتعديلات القضائيه وقال البيت
الابيض في بيان انما يجري في اسرائيل
سيؤثر على امنها وجيشها
اما المتحدثه باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي ادريان واتسون فقالت في بيان ان
الولايات المتحده تشعر بقلق عميق
ما يجري في اسرائيل هو تحث القاده
الاسرائيليين بقوه على ايجاد حل وسط في
اقرب وقت ممكن واضاف البيان ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ناقش مؤخرا مع رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي
مؤكدا على ان دعم الولايات المتحده لامن
اسرائيل وديمقراطيتها لا يزال صارما
اعود اليك مره اخرى العربيه زياد حلبي
زياد قبل قليل تابعنا
بحل الحكومه في حال استجابه نتنياهو او
ردوخه بحسب تعبيره لهذه المطالب بتجميل او
الغاء التعديلات القضائيه هل يمكن فعلا حل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في بهذه الظروف ومن
اي طرف يمكن ان يقدم على هذه الخطوه
يقرا تماما استطلاعات الراي الاسرائيليه
الاخيره ويدرك بانه يهدد بمسدس فارغ عمليا
حاليا لانه في حال ذهبوا للانتخابات ليس
اكيدا ان يبقى اليمين في السلطه هذا وفق
استطلاعات الراي الاخير على الاقل في
اسرائيل والاحزاب التي اتطفت على السطح
مثل الحزبين المتطرفين حزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه
وحزب القوه اليهوديه اللي بين جبير كلاهما
قد يتراجع بشكل جذري ولكن هذا التصريح
ويخاطب القاعده اليمنيه المتشدده في
اسرائيل اكثر منه تهديد لبنيامين نتنياهو
هذا الائتلاف متماسك نسبيا لديه
اغلبيه مريحه في البرلمان ولكن ادرك
نتنياهو ايضا في اللحظه الاخيره تلقف هذا
الامر بان استمرار الاحتجاجات كما رايناها
الليله الماضيه كان سيطيح في نهايه المطاف
بكل هذه الحكومه وبكل هذه الاحزاب طيب
زياد وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه حسب ما
تابعنا في الخبر العاجل قبل قليل
ذهبت الى ما اشرت اليه في بدايه هذه
المقابله هو ان التعديلات بل ان نتنياهو
قررت اجيال خطابه حول التعديلات القضائيه
ما الذي يعنيه ذلك على صعيد المشهد زياد
يعني بانه يحاول اقناع
شريكي بان لا يتحولان الى خصمي
اقصدج عمليا يحاول ان يقنعهما بانه يريد
تعليق التشريعات لا الغاءها كي تعود بحوار
كهذا يعني او اخر مع الطرف الاخر في مرحله
مقبله وان هذا هو المخرج الوحيد من عدم
اشعال اسرائيل بشكل كامل في
الميدان ولهذا عمليا يؤجل
الكلمه التي كان من المفروض ان يلقيها بعد
نحو ربما ربع ساعه من الان حاليا باعتقادي
ستؤجل نصف ساعه على الاقل ريثما يقنع هذين
الشخصين بعدم كسر قواعد اللعبه ليس ذلك
فقط مشاكل لتنياهو لن تنتهي بهذا ايضا
هناك ضغط عليه الان باقاله وزير الع الذي
اوصله بعناده عمليا ورفضه التوقف لحظه
واحده في الهروله تجاه التشريعات الى ما
وصلت اليه الامور في اسرائيل وفي داخل
الكود ايضا رايت بالامس مشهدا
لافتا جلنت اقيل وزير الدفاع اقيل فقط
لانه قال انه يجب تعليق التشريعات لانها
تشكل خطر على امن اسرائيل معظم وزراء
الليكود الليله الماضيه قالوا ما قاله
غلند ولكن اضافوا جمله واحده اذا اوقف
نتنياهو ذلك سنؤيد
وكيبداو يعني يظهر وكمن لا يشقون عصا
الطاعه لنتنياهو ولكن هم عمليا تبنوا
تبنوا موقف قلن تماما في هذا الامر وكذا
ايضا معظم رؤساء الائتلاف ليس ذلك فقط
اليوم تم تجميد قانون درعي رئيس شاس وزيرا
الى الحكومه تم تجميده ايضا كي لا يعني
يكون هناك مشكله دستوريه وان تشطبه
المحكمه العليا وان تعادل كره الى
الاحتجاجات في الشارع لكن الامر باعتقادي
ايضا ليس في سيطره نتنياهو تماما وانما
ايضا بشكل كبير في سيطره المحتجين في
الشارع ولا نقصد المعارضه الاسرائيليه
بذلك المعارضه لا تسيطر على المظاهرات
وانما تركب الموجه وتنضم الى المتظاهرين
طيب قد قاده الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل لزياد
بحسن في العاجل يقولون نتمسك بالغاء
التعديلات القضائيه وليس مجرد تعليقها
ايضا في بدايه حديثك زياد تحدثنا عن حوار
ربما يتم بين حزب الليكود او بين بنياهو
وقاده المعارضه في حال تاجيل هذه
الاصلاحات القضائيه كيف سيكون شكل هذه
الحوارات على اي اساس وما الذي يمكن ان
تفضي اليه ما هي النقطه الوسط التي يمكن
ان يصل اليها نتنياهو مع المعارضه حتى يتم
تمرير هذه الاصلاحات بالشكل الذي يمكن ان
يراعي مصالح الطرفين
عمليا الواضح بالنسبه لمعارضين
الخطه
الاغلبيه الان كما قلنا في الشارع
الاسرائيلي يدركون بان الجل او او دعنا
نقول جزء كبير من هذه الخطه تاتي لمساعده
شخصين بشكل واضح الاول متهم بثلاث قضايا
فساد ويحاكم اسمه بن يمين نتنياهو والثاني
مدان عمليا بثلاث قضايا فساد اسمه اريه
درعي وما بينهما عمليا من احزاب اليمين في
اسرائيل
خطه اليمين لاضعاف المحكمه العليا عمرها
اكثر من عقد يعني هناك مجمع يميني امريكي
يهودي امريكي اسرائيلي اسمه مجمع كوهيله
مجمع اقتصادي سياسي عمليا وضع هذه الخطه
قبل سنوات وعمليا نتنياهو تبناها حرفيا
وطرحها على الاسرائي بدون مشاورات حتى
داخل الليكود لم يجري المشاورات اللازمه
لهذا عمليا ربما التعليق او تاجيل
التشريعات هو متنفس فقط الى فتره ما بعد
الاعياد بالنسبه للاسرائيليين لكن يصعب
الاشاره الان الى ربما نقطه توافقيه ما
بين المعارضه والائتلاف خاصه في لجنه
تعيين القضاه هناك نوع من الضغط لدى
الائتلاف بان يسيطر بشكل او باخر بنسبه
90% 70% هذه هي الخلافات على لجنه تعيين
القضاه بمعنى ان يعين السياسيون قضاه
المحكمه العليا بمعنى ان تكون بشكل او
باخر السلطه القضائيه خاضعه للسلطتين
التشريعيه
والتنفيذيه في اسرائيل لهذا ترى بان قاده
المحتجين قالوا لن نكتفي بالتعليق او بوقف
التشريعات وانما بقرار الغائها ش طب هذه
التشريعات عن الوجود طيب الموقف الامريكي
زياد يعني كيف يمكن توصيفه لجهه تاثيره
على المشهد الحالي في اسرائيل وهذه
الخلافات بين الاطراف
الافريقيا السياسيه دارنا نقول
طبعا الولايات المتحده منذ اللحظه الاولى
واوروبا كلها
ودول اخرى ايضا اوضحت لنتنياهو الحكومه
بانها ضد هذه الخطه خطه الانقلاب على نظام
القضاء في اسرائيل وان ذلك سيؤثر على
العلاقات ايضا لجهه قدره واشنطن على حمايه
اسرائيل في المحافل الدوليه لان اضعاف
المحكمه العليا في اسرائيل سيكشف
السياسيين والجنود في اسرائيل امام
المحاكمه في محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
بجرائم حرب عاده عندما يكون هناك مناقشه
داخليه في النظام القضائي المحلي المحكمه
الدوليه لا تتدخل وبالتالي هذا ما اوضحه
الامريكيون ليس ذلك فقط ابلغ نتنياهو بشكل
واضح بانه غير مرغوب فيه لزياره واشنطن
حاليا يعني لهذا امر يكاد يكون غير مسبوق
هناك ازمه حقيقيه في العلاقات الاسرائيليه
الامريكيه على ارضيه هذه
الاحتجاجات وارضيات هذه الخطه القضائيه
لدرجه بان الموضوع موضوع ايران مثلا ونووي
اصبح ثالثا في المناقشات الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه الاخيره بمعنى عندما ياتي
مسؤول امريكي لاسرائيل يطرح اولا الخطه
القضائيه والاحتجاجات وضروره عدم فرض
تغييرات تجحف بحقوق الاقليات وما الى ذلك
الامر الاخر الموضوع الفلسطيني وعدم
الانفجار فيه والامر الثالث هو ايران هذا
يعني قلب للموازين وللعلاقات البينيه بين
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل فقط للتذكير
هناك وفد امني امريكي مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
موجود منذ يومين يعالج موضوع التحضير
لمساله مواجهه مع ايران وما الى ذلك ما
ينقله الاعلام الاسرائيلي عن الاجواء هناك
بان الامور باتت معقده جدا الجيش
الاسرائيلي عمليا قياده الاركان بشكل بدات
تفقد الثقه بالمستوى السياسي بعد اقاله
وزير الدفاع لانه فقط حذر من ان هناك
مخاطر امنيه تترتب عن خطه نتنياهو
الفضائيه وهذا ما يقال ان وزير الدفاع
المقالي تعبر عنه في اجتماعه الاخير مع
نتنياهو الذي هو طبعا يعتبر وزير الدفاع
هو حلقه الوصل بين الحكومه والمؤسسه
العسكريه والذي يعني
حاله الغضب والقلق في الداخل داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه هناك ايضا بعض الحديث الذي كان
يستاهل عن امكانيه حدوث انقلاب عسكريه في
الداخل الاسرائيلي ذلك وارد زياد رغم ان
ذلك لم يحدث في تاريخ اسرائيل القريب او
البيت
لا لا حدوث اضاء ضئيله جدا كان ان يحدث
هذا الامر يعني ان ترى دبابات اسرائيليه
تاتي الى تحاصر منزل نتنياهو مثل ما حدث
مع شوشسكو وما الى ذلك هذا مستبعد ولكن ما
كان يمكن ان يحدث ان النتيجه في المحصله
ستقود الى شيء من الفوضى يصل الى هذا الحد
بمعنى كان يمكن ان ما كان يمكن ان يحدث هو
ان يكون هناك تقويض وتفكك داخل الجيش
الاسرائيلي في احد اهم روافد هذا الجيش
وهي قوات الاحتياط الاسرائيليه وان يمتد
ذلك الى ايضا الضباط في القوات النظاميه
في اسرائيل للتذكير ثلاثه ارباع الجيش
الاسرائيلي هي قوات احتياط وليست قوات
نظاميه بالتالي العصيان الذي بدا من سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي اعطيك مثالا عندما يقول
عشرات الطيارين الحربيين في قوات الاحتياط
وكلهم من رتب عاليه بانهم يقاطعون
التدريبات هذا يعني بانه بعد شهر من الان
هم غير جاهزين للمشاركه في غارات ضد اهداف
ايرانيه في سوريا او حتى في مشاركه في
ضربه للمنشات النوويه في سوريا ولهذا
قالوا بالامس بان على نتنياهو ان يختار ان
اراد ان يواجه النووي الايراني في مرحله
ما ان يختار ما بين هذه الخطه القضائيه
وما بين القدره او بين مشاركه هؤلاء
الطيارين في حتى في ضربه في ايران يعني لا
يمكن كان في اسرائيل ان يتصور احد ان
يتحدى الطيارون حربيون في اسرائيل بهذا
الشكل طبعا انا فقدت الاتصال تماما
طيب يبدو انك لا تسمعني اذا زياد
من القدس اذا كنت معنا مراسل العربيه زياد
حلبي
شكرا لك زياد وسنعود اليك في سياق هذه
النشره
مشاهدينا من القدس ايضا ينضم الى الدكتور
مصري استاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
العبريه اهل الدكتور مهير وبدايه هل تتفق
مع ما ذهب اليه زياد حربي قبل قليل في
حديثه
وربما يلجا في خطابه المؤجل بحسب بعض
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه الى الحديث عن
تاجيل فقط وليس الغاء لهذه التعديلات
القضائيه
نوع من اتفق مع هذا استاذي الكريم لانه
بمنتهى البساطه لو ساده نيو اعلن عن عدول
الحكومه عن مشروعها فبالتالي هذا سوف يكون
معناه سقوط الحكومه لانه هناك عناصر داخل
الحكومه وحتى داخل الكود وهذه نقطه اهم
لانه لو كان المساله فقط مساله
وحده داخل الائتلافه ربما كان نتنياه ضحى
باحد الاحزاب المتطرفه
وعوض ذلك بادخال حزب اخر من قوى الوسط على
سبيل المثال حزب تكثر من اجل الدوله
برئاسه ميني جانز هذا حزب مؤهل تماما او
الاحرق قائمه انتخابيه مؤهله تماما لان
باسم الوحده الوطنيه للبلاد والحفاظ على
مصالح البلاد العليا تدخل في الحكومه
تشارك فيها بدلا من احد الاحزاب المتطرفه
ولكن الاشكاليه هنا هو انه الانشقاق هو
داخل الليكود نفسه اي ان هناك عناصر
متشدده داخل حزب الليكود وعلى راسهم الرجل
الثاني في ليكود اليوم وهو وزير العدل
السيد ليفين وبالتالي من الصعب انا اعتقد
انت تتم
العدول تماما عن المشروع ولكنه سوف يؤجله
ولا اريد ان اعطي مثال استاذي الكريم تفضل
شعار نتنياهو الانتخابي قبل اربع سنوات
كان ضم غور الاردن وقال انه هذا
مشروع حياته وانه
للحفاظ على امن البلاد وان هناك توافق
فيما يتعلق بهذه النقطه في اليمين وبحصل
على موافقه وعملت اسرائيل انذاك على
الحصول على موافقه من الرئيس ترامب لاداره
الامريكيه بانه سوف يبارك هذه الخطوه وقال
رئيس انه هو شان اسرائيلي داخلي ضم مرور
الاردن ولكن حينما اشترطت دوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده
عدول اسرائيل عن هذه الخطوه مقابل
التوقيع على معاهده سلام وبدء الخطوات في
سمي فيما بعد باستلام الابراهيم مع عده
دول فيما بعد
كان ها هنا الخيار هو او العدول عن
المشروع او التنازل عن
مشروع السلام الاقليمي وبالتالي تنازل عن
الضم غير الاذن ولكنه قال انه يؤجلها يؤجل
هذا الموضوع وهناك اشياء كثيره في الماضي
حقيقه تم تاجيلها ولكن تاجلت الى حتى
اليوم حتى هذه اللحظه وبالتالي انا اعتقد
انه من المهم نعم الصياغه لها لها اهميه
كبيره بالنسبه في هذا الظرف الدقيق انا لا
اعتقد انه سوف يلغي المشروع ولكنه سوف
يؤجله هناك
الاشكاليه هي هذه نقطه النقطه هامه للغايه
هو انه مطالب شائعه اليوم ارتفعت مطالب
الشارع ارتفعت بسبب طبعا انه اولا
نجح في فرض ارادته وشعر بنوع من الضعف عند
نتنياهو وثلا هذه النقطه الاهم وهو انه
نجح في استقطاب عناصر داخل الليكود نواب
في محسوبين على الكود
ولا انه وزير الدفاع هو لم يعارض المشروع
هو فقط قال ان هذا المشروع يجب ان يؤجل
فيها ولكنه اصبح بطلا لدى الشارع ولد
القوى المعارضه وانا اعتقد انه مساله
استماله عناصر داخل الليكود هذا اللي هو
اليوم التحدي الاكبر امام الشارع وامام
المعارضه اعتقد انه ارتفاع مطالب الشعب
نعم قد تؤدي الى صدام ولكن في هذه اللحظه
انا اعتقد انه سوف تكون بادره جيده
تجميد الاعلان عن تجميد المشروع لحين
البدء مفاوضات مع المعارضه في اطار
المبادره التي تقدم بها الرئيس
تحدثنا عن تجميد لهذا المشروع او حتى دعنا
نسلم انه تم الغاءه تماما يعني كيف يمكن
قراءه مستقبل نتنياهو السياسي بعدما حدث
انا اعتقد انه هو الخسا الاكبر لانه اولا
حسب استطلاعات الراي اللي كود خسر سته الى
سبعه مقاعد وهذا معناه انه اللي يقول لن
يكون مؤهلا لو اجريت انتخابات بالتشريع
مبكره
في وضع يسمح له بتشكيل حكومه هذه النقطه
الاولى ثانيا داخل حزب اليكود اليوم برضه
اسماء جديده على الساحه سواء كان الاكثر
تشددا سيد ليفين او عناصر اخرى كيواف على
سبيل المثال او يوليو وهم الذين يمثلون
اليوم عنصر الاعتدال داخل الحزب
وبالتاليها طبعا لا يزال الرجل الاول
والاقوى والمهيمن ولكن ليس بشكل مطلق كما
كان قبل اسابيع وبالتالي لا شك في انه هو
ثانيا ثانيا لو استمر في
بالاحرى لو قرر العدول عن المشروعه بشكل
بشكل تام كما تطالب به المعارضه وكما
يطالب بالشارع فانا اعتقد ان هناك احتمال
كبير الحكومه وهل السيد جانس سوف
يوافق على الالتحاق بالحكومه لانقاذها
وتعويضها عن خروج عناصر متطرفه ان نعتقد
ان السيد جنس اليوم وفي وضع الحالي سوف
يضحي بشعبيته ويذهب لينقذ حكومه وبالتالي
انا ارجح ان تسقط الحكومه لو
احتدت الامور وذهبت الحكومه الى الغاء
التام لمشروع الاصلاح القضائي من ناحيه
اخرى لو بالعكس لو بالعكس تمادى سيده في
عناده
[موسيقى]
الاعراف هناك فصل بين السلطات لا يمكن
الحكومه بان تمرر اي مشروع قانون يصطدم
المشاريع بقوانين اساس يصطدم بوثيقه
الاستقلال وبشريه الاساس ووثيقه الاستقلال
يمثلوا الدستور في اسرائيل
غير مكتوب اي انه مكتوب ولكن في نصوص
مختلفه ومتناثره وبالتالي هذا قانونيا لا
يجوز كما انه المحكمه العليا هي
الجهاز الوحيد الذي يحد ويحجم من قوه
الاغلبيه
وبالتالي الغائه تماما هو شيء خطير للغايه
فيما يتعلق بمبدا الفصل بين السلطات ولا
تنسوا استاذي الكريم انه في نظام نيابه لا
يوجد فصل التنفيذيه وسلطه تشريعيه حيث ان
الحكومه مهيمنه تماما على البرلمان
الكنيست لانها منبثقه عنه بمنتهى البساطه
وبالتالي الفصل بين السلطات يقتضي بانه
على الاقل تكون هناك جهه قضائيه عليا
تراقب عمل الحكومه
يعني هنفهم ذلك ان الازمه هل هي ازمه
دستوريه ام قانونيه ام سياسيه دكتور
طبيعه هذه الازمه الان حسب ما تفضلت بها
هي ازمه سياسيه ام قانونيه ام دستوريه
هي ازمه الدستوريه اي انها ازمه فوق
قانونيا يعني اهم من كونها
سياسيه لانه السؤال الذي يطرح نفسه هو
ان اثرت الحكومه على مشروع قانون المحكمه
العليا ترفض الاقرار بدستوريته
وحينئذ الرئيس فارفض التوقيع عليه
فبالتالي سوف يعلو على من سوف يعلو على من
سوف يمرر بالقوه الوزير العدل يقول نحن
اذا صدمنا بالمحكمه سوف نمرر بالقوه وهو
قال هذا الكلام بالقوه مشروع القلب هذا لا
يجوز قانونيا والمحكمه العليا تقول نحن
سوف نمنع دخول مثل هذه المشاريع حيث تنفيذ
لانها غير دستوريه اذا من سوف يفرض ارادته
وبالتالي طالما انه هذا السؤال يطرح اذا
الازمه اصبحت ازمه دستوريه والصدام القائم
هو ليس معرض مع الدوله مع مؤسسات الدوله
شكرا لك من القد كنت معنا الدكتور علوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه
مشاهدينا نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
الحكومه اللبنانيه تجتمع اليوم لبحث ازمه
التوقيتين الصيفي والشتوي
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد نسالف نشرت من
تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث انهى جنود
الاوكرانيون تدريب استمر منذ بدايه فبراير
الماضي في بريطانيا وذلك لاستخدام دبابات
اثنين التي تعهدت المملكه المتحده بنقلها
الى كييف يذكر انه بتاريخ رابع عشر من
يناير الماضي كانت المملكه المتحده اول
دوله غربيه تعلن انها تنقل اربع عشره
دبابه قتال رئيسيه من طراد تشالنجر اثنين
الى كييفل
اعلن وزير الدفاع البريطاني
ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ستتلقى
الدبابات قبل بدايه الصيف لكنها لم تذكر
تواريخ دقيقه لهذا الامر
هذا وكشف المتحدث باسم حارس الحدود
الاوكراني عن تقلص اعداد الجنود الروسي
بيلاروسيا الروس في بيلاروسيا الى 4000
جندي وقال
ان المعلومات المتوفره تشير الى ان اعداد
الجنود الروس داخل بيلاروسيا وعلى حدود
اوكرانيا كانت تقدر بنحو عشره الاف جندي
لكنها اليوم تراجعت الى نحو 4000 جندي
بعد فضائح الفساد في الجيش يواجه الرئيس
الاوكراني فضائح في صفوف المتطوعين
الاجانب الذين دخلوا في الظاهر للقتال
الضروس لكن تبين ان اغلبهم عديم الخبره
العسكريه نتابع
الاف المتطوعين الاجانب وصلوا الى
اوكرانيا بطلب من الرئيس زيلينسكي اعدادهم
تراوحت بين 20 و70 الفا الا ان 1500 مقاتل
فقط لا زالوا في اوكرانيا الكثير من
المتطوعين يمتلكون خبره فعليا اما البقيه
فاستغلوا فرصه المشاركه في حرب حقيقيه
فساد وخيانه واختلاس لاموال التبرعات
وبعضهم لا يمتلك اي خبره عسكريه صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز اطلعت على 100 حاله مماثله
ونشرت تفاصيل بعض الحالات جيمس فاسكاس
ادعى مشاركته في حرب الخليج وغزو العراق
البنتاغون اكد ان فاسكاز لا يمتلك اي خبره
عسكريه كما انه نشر مواقع كتيبته بدقه عبر
الانترنت
دليل سياحي في امريكا ولا يمتلك اي خبره
عسكريه جرادي تم عزله من الفيلق الاجنبي
في اوكرانيا قبل ان يختلس اموال التبرعات
الموجهه لكييف
ريبلايجانس عقيد امريكي متقاعد اتهمه
بتسريب التكنولوجيا امريكيه زود اوكرانيا
بمناظير ليليه متقدمه ممنوعه من التصدير
قبل ان يؤسس شركه استخدمها في تبييض
الاموال جون ماكينتيرن جندي امريكي سابق
تم فصله من اللفيف الاجنبي
ماكينتر سلم معلومات حساسه الى العدو قبل
ان يفر الى روسيا ويقل من تلفزيونها
الرسمي
وامام العقوبات الدوليه المفروضه على
روسيا من الغرب افاد تقرير صحيفه
لنقل النفط ما قد يتسبب في مخاطر بيئيه
حسب التقرير
طريق ملتفه تعتمدها موسكو لنقل نفطها عبر
اسطول الظل الذي يضم اكثر من 100 ناقله
تفتقل لوثائق التامين على الشحن بسبب
العقوبات الغربيه نقلات نفطيه يتجاوز
عمرها 15 عاما منها الناقله توربا التي
تبحر تحت عالم الدوله ذات المكانه الضعيفه
للاشراف على السلامه البحريه وهي
الكاميرون وتقوم بنقل الملايين من براميل
النفط دون تامين مناسب حيث كشف تقرير صادر
عن صحيفه
بان استمرار موسكو باستخدام هذا النوع من
السفن القديمه التي لا يتم فحصها وصيانتها
بشكل صحيح ينطوي على اخطار بيئيه كبيره قد
تتسبب في اسوا تسربات للنفط في التاريخ
الاوروبي ما لا يقل عن اربعين سفينه قديمه
ابحرت لالاف الاميال من ميناء سان
بطرسبرجر الروسي وقامت بنقل النف الى
الصين والهند وتركيا بين اوائل ديسمبر
واوائل فبراير الماضي كما تقوم بعض السفن
بنقل حمولاتها الخطيره في اعالي البحار في
المياه الدوليه قباله اليونان او معبر
السبت الاسباني شمال افريقيا وهي مخاطره
ضخمه تهدد الملاحه البحريه الاوروبيه
والعالميه خصوصا وان ناقله توربا فقط نقلت
مؤخرا الاورال درجه الخامه الروسيه
الرئيسيه الى الهند واذا ابحرت الى اسيا
فستتضمن الابحار في بحر البلطيق وعبور
العديد من السواحل الاوروبيه رحله الوقود
الروسي وفق تقرير سابق لفايناشن تايمز
كانت تبدا من محطه تكرير تابعه لعملاق
النفط الروسي لوك اويل في جزيره صقليه
الايطاليه وهي التي سمحت لروسيا بتحقيق
مكاسب ماديه حتى بعد فرض العقوبات
ترقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان اتصالا هاتفيا من وزير خارجيه
ايران
وجرى خلال الاتصال مناقشه عدد من
الموضوعات المشتركه في ضوء الاتفاق
الثلاثي الذي تم التوقيع عليه في الصين
كما اتفق وزير خارج السعوديه ونظير ايراني
على عقد لقاء ثنائي خلال شهر رمضان
في لبنان وبعد الجدل الكبير المتصل
بالتوقيتين شتوي والصيفي دعا رئيس الحكومه
اللبنانيه نجيب ميقاتي مجلس الوزراء الى
جلسه ظهر اليوم ووجهت الامانه العامه
لمجلس الوزراء دعوه الى الوزراء لحضور
جلسه في السرايا الكبير لمناقشه قرار
تعديل التوقيت بعد ان قرر رئيس مجلس
الوزراء الموافقه استثنائيا على تاجيل
تطبيق قرار مجلس الوزراء رقم خمسه المتعلق
بتعديل التوقيت
ينشغل الامريكيون من جديد باخبار ترامب
وحملته الرئاسيه الجديده
ليشغل الحياه السياسيه والاعلاميه في
الولايات المتحده ونادرا ما تنظر الى
برنامج سياسي من دون ان يكون الحديث حول
دونالد ترامب وتشير اخر استطلاعات الراي
الى انه يتقدم على اقرب منافسيه
الجمهوريين
حاكمس باكثر من عشر نقاط ويتقدم على
الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن في الانتخابات
العامه باربعين نقاط مئويه
السلاح الجديد الذي يستعمله الديمقراطيون
في الانتخابات وملاحقه مرشح بتهمه جنائيه
ويصنعون دعايه وهذا من مصلحتي فشعبيه صعدت
الى اعلى مستوى
واستغل محامي ترامب برامج الاحد السياسيه
ليقول ان مدعي عام نيويورك يعمل بتوجيه من
اداره بايدن التي تسعى لاحباط حمله ترامب
الرئاسيه
وليشدد ايضا على ان الاموال التي تم دفعها
للممثله الاباحيه
هي اموال شخصيه وليست اموال الحمله
الانتخابيه
هذه اموال شخصيه وكيف ما نظرت الى المساله
فهي اموال شخصيه وليست اموال حمله
انتخابيه
ولو رات هيئه المحلفين او من بعدها
المحكمه في نيويورك ان الاموال هي بالفعل
اموال شخصيه لسقطت هذه القضيه القانونيه
برمتها وبقي فقط الضجيج الذي اثارته
والمخاوف التي تسببت بها ومنها ما اعتبره
الديمقراطيون دعوه من قبل ترامب لاستعمال
العنف في الشارع
كلنا يتذكر الرعب في السادس من يناير وما
تسبب به الرئيس حينداك دونالد ترامب
واليوم يقول الامر ذاته وقد قدمت الاف بي
اي اجازا لي وهم مستعدون
يبقى دونالد ترامب صاحب اكبر قاعده شعبيه
في صفوف الحزب الجمهوري وهو يتقدم باشواط
في حملته الانتخابيه على كل منافسيه
الحزبيين وربما ايضا الرئيس الديمقراطي
الحالي
في الغنمه العربيه واشنطن
وفي نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه نذكر
بعبرز العناوين
وسط غليان في الجامعات والشارع مصادر
بيليكوت تشير لعزم نتنياهو التراجع عن
التعديلات القضائيه
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي يدخل على خط
الازمه ويحث قاده اسرائيل على ايجاد حل
وسط في اقرب وقت
روسيا تقلص عدد جنودها في بيلاروسيا الى
4000 وجنود الاوكرانيون ينهون تدريباتهم
على الدبابات اثنين
نهايته في امان الله
[موسيقى]